let's bring in the syracuse head coach
good morning coach how are you I've
never been in a worse time worst place
and that I can remember and I'm sure
everybody is in the same boat amen
how did you hear about the tournament
being canceled yeah we were in the
morning going out looking at some tape
of Louisville which you know we didn't
like looking at that so when the worst
loss we had this year and you know just
looking at their getting ready and you
know coming off the best game we played
all year so had some optimism obviously
but you know you thought it was coming I
think really one of the problems is when
the NBA cancelled that you know it kind
of pushed everybody a little bit and the
one thing that bothers the only thing
that I mean we have to do this there's
probably no question about that but the
thing that bothers me with the NBA and
baseball and golf they often take 30
days off and they can come back and
hopefully it'll be good I mean they'll
be able to we don't know that but
hopefully 30 40 days things will be
we'll see what's there and we'll see
maybe we can now go forward and they all
can resume college athletes are done
they're done and you know I knew that
when they cancelled the tournament that
that day the answer your turn was over
because you're in a week you're not
going to know two weeks you know what is
it maybe a month won't be enough maybe
it would be two months and any
irregardless the college seasons over
and for our sport I mean I look at a
team like Dayton I look at a team that
just won their conference tournament and
a major upset and those players are the
most excited I've ever been in their
life and now that's all gone
I look at our lacrosse that men's
lacrosse team is number one in the
country or one of those teams number
four Cornell right down the road men's
lacrosse number two those guys have
worked at tails off I mean to just it's
all gone
and maybe we'll look back and this is a
hundred percent the right thing to do I
hope it is but you have to feel for
those kids who have put themselves into
that position and and you know I'm sure
I'm sending players home we're sending
players home and is that a good thing we
have players from New York is that a
good thing to send them there so I you
know I don't know what the answers are
I just feel for all these college
athletes that have worked their whole
life to get to the NC double-a
tournament and and now that's gone so I
hope it's time I hope for all I hope
this is the right thing to do
Geno Auriemma said that maybe we should
allow these seniors to be able to come
back to play I don't know if we could do
a one-time exemption code I think you
can do incidentally is we found in the
past can do anything they want to do
would you be in favor this yeah I mean
again we're talking about student
athletes you know are we gonna do what's
right for them I think it's more true of
especially remember when the Duke
obviously we don't want to think about
when the Duke thing happened in lacrosse
years not that long those kids all came
back I think a significant portion of
them did and I think they even won the
national championship I might be off a
little bit but I think they might have
and/or come close yeah there's precedent
for it I don't see why not
I think in basketball you may have
difficulty recreating that but yeah I
mean I don't see why you couldn't do
that there's some precedent for it yeah
I think so I think that's it that's a
good idea you didn't have that vision no
no do you don't worry Imogen yes yeah my
only concern is what are you going to
talk about for the next two months
dan Patrick rerun time or what Koni I
don't know coach I I'm worried about you
I'm really worried because I'm home and
I've their home a day now my wife is
looking at me cross-eyed and we can't
recruit and we can't you know work those
out we can't yeah I don't know what's
gonna this is not gonna be good way so
you you can't hold a practice or any
kind of workouts as far as I know
nothing and I mean I think that we'll be
looking at some point but I'm worried
about our three or four foreign guys
what are they gonna do they can't go
home so we've got to figure that out I'm
worried about academics you know our
guys you know we have fortunately we
have good students but they're used to
having tutoring and help and if they all
go home what happens there so I'm
worried about all that stuff I don't
know if you saw this yesterday but the
Big East actually tipped off and then
cancelled it happen
coach what the hell was going on there I
did well I think you know I I know I'm
wrong when I say this but if there was a
czar of college sports and college
basketball and I was it I would have
said let's play these tournaments this
weekend with no fans let's look at what
happens Monday or Tuesday where are we
and I mean there was no appetite for
that but I think I would have I would
have thought something like that that's
what I was thinking really when they
decided to start playing the conference
comments let's let's play them see where
we are but again I think once the
decision was made to send students home
by the Ivy League schools and some other
schools I think then it had to follow
well we can't have spring sports because
we've sent the students home we can't
now keep the athletes here but the
public public pressure it felt like that
was pretty heavy and that that played a
large role in this yeah I think there
was a lot of pressure no question about
it and
and this again we will look back and say
this was a right decision 100% but I
don't think anybody knows right now you
see there's a doctor - - I think
well-respected doctors that we're
talking about this is you know if you're
healthy you're going to get a cold
you're going to be sick for a couple
days and you're gonna be alright
but that might be wrong it might be the
other way where we have to stop this
down this is the best way to do it but
when you send students home where are
they going to go out they're gonna go to
the mall they're gonna go to clubs
they're gonna be out in the public
they're not going home and stay in their
apartment or their house so I mean
there's danger for the students wherever
they go talking to some places they go
it's going to be more dangerous than it
is here in Syracuse talking to Jim
Boeheim Syracuse head coach at least you
won your last game well you know isn't
15 that was the last game of the other
national championship I don't know I
just wondered about that do you want to
declare yourself the national champs no
I think that would be a stretch okay
Jim Boeheim celebrate go out there and
cut down the nets today you're always
happy to win that game and we played
we've been up and down with a young team
we've had some really good wins and
we've had some terrible losses but North
Carolina just came in here and beat us
at home but 11 or 12 it was probably
could have been 15 and to go down there
and play in North Carolina and win that
game we just played a great game so it's
a good memory for all of our young
players our young players all played
well you know we have no seniors so it
was it was a great way to end the season
basketball wise but I just feel bad for
all these teams you know that
once-in-a-lifetime you know you look
back on the NC double-a tournament and
all the players I've had that's what
they look back at their experience
answer double-a tournament you know
especially a really good experience
sweet 16 or final four I mean that's
what college players look back on and
it's tough for that all to be gone it's
probably a hundred percent the right
thing to do but it's it still doesn't
feel good for all those players the
Oregon women's great player C man s crew
comes back for a senior year and you
know it's gone I know I lacrosse team i
watch TV I love lacrosse it's a great
sport might be better than any sport to
watch for me and these guys work out all
year long I mean they they live and died
again into the n-c-double-a tournament
and do something and you know it's but
this is the times we live in
based on all the information around the
world it looks like we have to do these
things but it still doesn't make it any
easier you got oh honey you got a hobby
you know I used to play golf so bad now
I try to go fishing but when you go out
there I can't catch fish now you really
got a problem so it's like you know
you're not you know fishing is one thing
the idea of your fishing is to catch
fish and I haven't figures I don't know
yet
and I do a lot of fishing but not on
catching not catching I think you know I
like guys that can I go one guy that
catches so when I go with him we I catch
a few but it's not that easy you know
fishing did you hear that
Fritzie son who probably answers the
phone every time you call Fritzie son is
going to Syracuse next year I didn't
know that yeah I know that
I hope we're here and I hope everything
is good and I hope we get through this
like everybody is praying for that and
you're still planning on being there
coaching right no other place this might
extend my career this as a brook and
people are gonna forget that you
probably weren't going to make the
tournament and then you get another year
well you know we can always say she's
we're on a roll we didn't think
[Music]
we almost can count this is well yeah we
were we would have been in a yeah you
would have gone on a roll you would have
you would have you know yeah yeah you
would have Rhea and revenge against
Louisville absolutely we're gonna hold
to the to defend little hope and that's
all that it's gonna be but I just you
know it's this is just such a time and
you know all we do now this time here
when we're done is watch the tournament
and get ready to get our players ready
for next year get to our academic stuff
get recruiting them you know with the
transfers and everything now you're
recruiting all year long you know
there's no offseason you're recruiting
even for next year now not for the year
after you're recruiting for this coming
year so there's so many changes and
that's gone so it's it's going to be a
difficult adjustment but you know we
have to make sure that we stay as
healthy as possible I'm a little worried
my son's at Cornell they're still going
to class I can't figure that out they're
usually smarter we are my son always
says when there's an issue about we're
having a disagreement he says well I go
to Cornell okay then he also said he is
a cold he's afraid to come home and
infect me he's worried about me I'm 75
so I don't know and your ranch you got
to be worried about this yeah I'm
healthy at 73 I'd say maybe and you
might be a little optimistic there but
he looks younger than you well here's
what do you try he is I mean he looks a
lot younger than you
well you guys is here I'm sure Wow sure
Wow I think if a good times I just lost
my best friend I'm in trouble now so no
it'll never get out I know you won't get
that board but if you do get bored and
need to call in and just talk to
somebody you know you're right I don't
know give me any idea what you even know
I know we got free agency
football free agencies coming up here
that they'll hold the draft well the one
thing you know is there will be football
because well there's nothing else there
will be professional football are you a
Buffalo Bills fan bye son Jimmy is of
course he's at Cornell you have to
understand that I've always been a
Patriots fan am I like Belichick and
Brady and has the opportunity meet Brady
was devices he was I mean that I know
there's a little three-quarters of your
fan bases man that mean I like Tom Brady
but nicest guys talked to in a long time
and did he talk to the players when he
came up it was great thought we I mean
we had a harsh game and usually I don't
I don't even talk to the players when we
lose like that north but he was great he
gave four or five minutes to them that
was I thought really
he just hit every right chord and you
know I I've been a big fan here so I'm
just gonna come out and say this he he
loves to play football you know a lot of
times you guys want to keep their job
they want to play they want to they want
the limelight or they want the money or
whatever it is
this guy just he's lost you could see it
it's coming out of them he just loves to
play did he tell you he's gonna stay
with the Patriots he did not tell me
that I did not ask him that I'd like to
be friends with him or at least well you
got to show you care about him so you
would ask him about you'd say I was an
avid Patriots fan yeah and my son buddy
it's an avid patriot fan and that that's
as far as I took it but I you know we'll
see we had Edelman was up here he was
great and you know they were it was just
great to have them up here they're just
two class guys and their message was was
great and
I just want you know I want I'm ready to
play a good football team and show that
he can do something that has never been
done before
and I think if there's one guy that can
play when he's 43 years old and do it
well I think it's him I really do know
the only thing we had Rob Gronkowski up
here the only thing I asked him in his
last year it was just at the end of his
last year
how does Brady for the football in
comparison he said coach just as good as
he ever threw it never and now that that
was interesting who retires first you
were Brady oh that's a close call that's
a close call it depends how good we are
our fans weren't too happy with me this
year they weren't living like like you
know you might be too old here but see
what happens all right well my best your
wife is good god she's gonna have to put
up with you finally Tommy Jim final
party yeah just give me the evil look
right now that I'm still here yeah well
the kids can't you go to work now take a
walk take a walk she said she said go to
work or do the laundry one or the other
so and I cannot do the laundry so that's
out so I guess we're limited what we can
do and I'm sure you're not a bit better
than me so I'm not gonna feel bad
thank you thank you I appreciate your
time and said Jim Bay hunt